hey lar you there hey nari I'm here hey
I want to ask you a question first
listen to this sounds like a James Brown
song doesn't it yeah but it's not what
is it about this that we're both hearing
that makes us think of James Brown
what's going on musically that makes
James Brown sound like James Brown
scream spins and splits all make for a
great show but what was the minister of
the new news super heavy funk doing to
answer that question we have to go back
to 1964 when funk was born so a lot of
people say that funk started with Papa's
got a brand-new bag in 1965 others say
it started in 1967 with cold sweat but
James Brown says in his autobiography
that his sound really started to change
in 1964 with his album out of sight out
of sight was another beginning musically
and professionally you can hear the band
in me start to move in a whole nother
direction rhythmically the horns the
guitar the vocals everything was
starting to be used to establish all
kinds of rhythms at once I was trying to
get every aspect of the production to
contribute to the rhythmic patterns
Brown got away from melodies this music
was very rhythmically focused even the
Tambor his delivery style was percussive
and I think that's what made funk at
such a grooving such a popular sound
because even the musicians they are
they're not really always singing it's
more brutal chanting but it's not driven
by a series of chords is driven by
rhythmic interactions and not only was
he using every instrument to add to the
songs rhythmic pattern but he was
creating a whole new pattern so most
music of that era gave heavy emphasis to
the backbeat on the two and the four of
the measure and sounded like this one
two three four James Brown did was he
put the emphasis on the one on the
downbeat of the measure and that sounds
like
[Music]
[Music]
emphasizing the one created space in the
group so that the band could add
syncopation to the other beats
syncopation is just placing rhythms or
accents in places where we don't expect
it so if these are the strong beats
three four one two three four
syncopation is just putting accents in
between the strong beats so sound like
one and two and three so here are some
of the observations that I picked up
while listening to James Brown songs the
first thing is that his voice is very
good the quality of how he how he sings
is almost shouting and singing it's
somewhere in between and his melodies
and phrases are more like staffs rather
than long lyrical melodies this is James
Brown and we're doing sound feel y'all
make it [ __ ] it I want to do my thing
you know moving grooving is that Alright
yes up James we'll take very simplistic
approaches he would take a lyric and
give it rhythm and then he would wrap it
with his soul and dip it in fun ah that
was preaching you know and when they
would preach they would have you know
it's called Nixon it's all from the Good
Life Church his influence was more the
preacher than the thing is per se in
some phrasing and then booth United inin
and and the preacher they are performing
in a style that generates responses from
the congregation does a very same thing
on stage he is catering to the needs of
his audience and they understood they
identified with his performance and
that's why he remains so popular at the
same time it is also the reason
he did not write really the pop charts
it was too much it was just too black
yes do you remember the song that I
played for LA the one that sounded like
James Brown well it's pretty close it's
actually Bobby Byrd James Brown
songwriting partner sidekick and
Heitmann listen to James Brown calling
out for Byrd on his hit song sex machine
[Music]
song that's actually Bobby bird calling
for us to get on the use of this gospel
inspired column response and vocal
punctuation x' have inspired generations
of hip-hop artists you can even hear
brown's influence in today's ad-libs
[Music]
Ellie and I are going to write a song
influenced by James Brown and given the
fact that I'm not that well versed in
funk I'm not sure what we'll come up
with but we'll give it a try okay so
nari I've had this beat in my head for a
long time and if James Brown was still
here with us today this is what I would
give to him are you ready yeah Wow -
[Music]
nice do you think you could add some
what some James Brown flavor to it
something that has maybe with a blues
scale
[Music]
okay
[Music]
how would I articulate this to make it
sound funky because I'm listening to it
look even if you added more space like
like like a bar of rest I'm saying so
but don't built better
did you just offset it yeah you don't
want to [ __ ] yeah okay yeah that kind of
body okay so mr. Moore nari and I we
created a song that's influenced by
James Brown alright and I love to play
it for you and tell me what you think
[Music]
yeah if you hear any in a James Brown
influence in there yeah that's that's
definitely I would say and its
importance today yeah the horn to make
it pop yeah that would be the extra
seasoning on it let's make it [ __ ] it
okay let us know in the comments below
what you thought of our song and some of
your favorite funky tunes also please
subscribe
[Music]